the cemetery
where he was laid to rest alongside his
parents
the streets lined by tens of thousands
of fans saying adios
to a great footballer a national hero
the loss was felt across the world
for us diego was eternal for a whole
life
he led argentina to the top it's
difficult for everyone
i've seen newspapers in france and in
england they all talk about him
it's incredible however the chaos that
lighted much of maradona's life
spilled into events marking his death
fans clashed with police after the gates
to the government palace where he was
lying in state
closed denying them the chance to pay
their last respects
with his death has come the opportunity
to reflect on what diego maradona gave
to the world of football
to this neighborhood to argentina the
answer for many
is everything they created shrines at
football grounds where he played at boca
juniors and here the argentinos junior's
ground
named after him where he began his
professional career as a
fifteen-year-old
in 1976. he said
diego is the people he's the people it's
what he most identified with he never
forgot his origins
the happiness he brought this family for
all these families
i don't want to judge him badly because
he represented all our misery
and as it says on these posters our
happiness too
i'd like to thank maradona for all the
happiness he brought us
i don't know some applause for maradona
the best of our people
thank you diego really thank you
[Applause]
they applauded here and across argentina
in naples and barcelona and around the
world
maradona and the demons he battled the
dead but diego the footballer his magic
his vision and ability to excite and
inspire live on in his fans
daniel schweinmer al jazeera buenos
aires